你自己一个人就可以试一下好公司
这个不是什么性感你啊
我之前在家里的心法里提到我
我一个人
就是一家公司
而且我个人从家旨会超过很多小型公司
随着AI人工只能出现
未来会出现一个人的主角受
你也可以试一下公司怎么做呢
留句话 我不解释
这六句话和六句话只跨至今
它是有连接的
首先我们说第一句话
一个好的伏业大的公司应该是
改变人们生活的
巴基云元利滅提到我
要记住干什么 什么人们服务的
对吧
那么能够改变人们生活的
产品
才是好产品
定句话
然后我们来说第二句话
停止幻想
停止思考的一些根本就不存在的数
照页改变你自己
第二句话和第一句话是连接担一戏的
第一句话是什么来的还行的吗
伟大的公司是改变人们生活的
改变人们生活的产品就是好产品
第三个就是现状这个遇到的问题
你能改变自己
别人需要吗 别人不需要
对不对
所以什么才是人们需要呢
我之前在家旨会计划也提到我
人们正常会需要什么 首先第一个就是生命健康
对吧 比如说老人他死了
然后扬生了 夫人他死了 对吧
我们说健身跑步
于家 明白明显
这个是这么多特别关心的话题
就好多社交媒体做没有一个不就扬生的
第二句话是什么呢 第二句话就是猜负
比如说我赚钱呀 传页呀 投资啊 李彩呀 赚在小钱呀 坐在小声一样
这个人们都特别喜欢 对吧
第三个文人们就说回关系
比如说 爱情啊 亲情啊 亲子啊
有了父母人的关系啊 同时人的关系啊 怎么结交共读的人啊 社交啊
这个人们也会特别喜欢啊 就很多地方就爱情就是个塞道啊 对吧
上下集也是个塞道啊
最后一个是什么就是我的作家这事情
比如说的幸福啊 我作家这些啊 我的个人成长啊 我的喜好啊 对吧
这个是什么关注的
只要你的改变
和人能关注的几个方面结合在一起 那他就是有市场的
所以一二三十年代一起的啊 这四个部分
你一个人就可以是家公司 但你不需要开公司
你可能需要一个社交问题
然后体会要后面的就话啊 社交媒体可能是一个人才市场
他可以是一所学校
可以是一个聚会
可以是一个你的这个笔记记录系统
我前两天和学生的老师聊天的时候 他说他之前开公司的时候周平啊
就不看你眼里
你办的社交媒体会看一下我就知道了
你像我之前开公司 我就要求这个拥护一定会给他吧
因为我糟过是程序的嘛 如果你没有对不起就直接爬死了 对吧
各位体会一下 你这社交媒体可以是个什么
本身就是个照片网站
就是一个公开的学校 你咱们可以学习
就是一个笔记记录 我可以把我很多东西发过出来
主义最久的话 他可以是一个笔记录
他可以是打新的聚会的现场
好 第五句话
关注你感兴趣的领域
去创造价值 去改变刺激
你可以先学习买
这时候你可能需要学习
一些什么写作亚 言讲
赢消啊 产品啊 这样的一些东西
然后一边去改变刺激
然后一边把这些东西分享出来
一边做一边学 其实飞满系统就是产品勾键的
又是赢消的 这样一个过程
最后一样
一样是行动 生活一顿的
立刻